[Música]
Albert emú creció rodeado de violencia
su tierra natal en Argelia estaba sumida
en un conflicto entre nativos argelinos
y los colonizadores europeos franceses
perdió a su padre en la Primera Guerra
Mundial y se le consideró no apto para
luchar en la segunda camu se desanimó al
combatir la tuberculosis en Francia y
confrontar la devastación de la guerra
como periodista de la resistencia no
podía entender el significado detrás de
todo este derramamiento de sangre y
sufrimientos sin fin se preguntaba si el
mundo no tenía sentido podrían seguir
teniendo valor nuestras vidas
individuales
muchos de los contemporáneos de camu
exploraban preguntas similares bajo una
nueva filosofía llamada existencialismo
los existencialistas creían que las
personas nacían como pizarras en blanco
cada uno responsable de crear
significado a su vida en medio de un
mundo caótico pero camor rechazó su
escuela de pensamiento argumentó que
todas las personas nacían como una
naturaleza humana compartida que los
unías y objetivos comunes un objetivo
era Buscar significado a pesar de la
crueldad arbitraria del mundo
movió el deseo de significado de la
humanidad y La silenciosa indiferencia
del universo como dos piezas
incompatibles de un rompecabezas
y pensó que tratar de unirlas era
fundamentalmente absurdo
esta tensión se convirtió en el núcleo
de la filosofía del absurdo de camu que
Consideró que la vida era inherentemente
fútil
explorar cómo vivir sin sentido se
convirtió en el principio rector detrás
del trabajo inicial de camu el cual
llamó el ciclo del absurdo
la estrella de este ciclo y primera
novela publicada de camu- ofrece una
respuesta bastante sombría el extranjero
sigue a su un joven emocionalmente
distante que no atribuye mucho
significado a nada
no llora en el funeral de su madre apoya
el plan de su vecino para humillar a una
mujer incluso comete un crimen violento
pero no siente remordimientos para él El
mundo no tiene sentido y el juicio moral
no tiene cabida en él
esta actitud crea hostilidad entre marzo
y la sociedad metódica en la que habita
y aumenta lentamente su alineación hasta
el clímax explosivo de la novela
A diferencia de su despreciado
protagonista camu fue notorio por su
filosofía honesta el extranjero lo
catapultó a la fama y continuó
produciendo trabajos que exploraron el
valor de la vida en medio del absurdo
muchos de los cuales regresaban a la
misma pregunta filosófica si la vida
realmente no tiene sentido
suicidarse es la única respuesta
razonable
la respuesta de camu fue un no rotundo
puede que no haya ninguna explicación
para nuestro mundo Injusto pero elegir
vivir De todas formas es la expresión
más profunda de nuestra genuina libertad
camu explica esto en uno de sus ensayos
centrado en el mito griego de sísifo
sísifo era un rey que engañó a los
dioses y fue condenado a subir una roca
por una colina sin cesar
la crueldad de su castigo radica en su
singular futilidad pero camu sostiene
que toda la humanidad está en la misma
posición y solo cuando aceptamos el sin
sentido de nuestras vidas podemos
afrontar lo absurdo con la cabeza bien
alta como dice camu cuando el rey decide
empezar su incesante tarea una vez más
uno puede imaginar así si fue feliz
los contemporáneos de camu no aceptaban
la futilidad
muchos existencialistas abogaron por una
Revolución violenta para volcar sistemas
que creían que privaban a la gente de
representación y propósito camur
respondió con su segundo trabajo el
ciclo de las Revolución en el hombre
Rebelde explora la rebelión como un acto
creativo en vez de uno destructivo camo
creía que invertir la dinámica del poder
sólo conduciría un ciclo interminable de
violencia en cambio la forma de evitar
un derramamiento de sangre innecesario
es establecer una comprensión pública de
nuestra naturaleza humana compartida
irónicamente fue este ciclo de ideas
relativamente pacíficas lo que
desencadenó repercusiones con muchos
colegas
a pesar de la controversia camu comenzó
a trabajar en su novela más larga y
personal hasta el momento un trabajo
autobiográfico titulado el primer hombre
la novela estaba destinada a ser el
primer paso una nueva y prometedora
dirección el ciclo del amor pero en 1960
camo murió repentinamente en un
accidente de auto que solo puede ser
descrito como sin sentido y absurdo
Aunque el mundo Nunca vio su ciclo de el
amor sus ciclos de rebelión y absurdo
continúan resonando entre los lectores
hoy en día su concepto del absurdo se
convirtió en parte del mundo de la
literatura la filosofía del siglo XX e
incluso la cultura pop hoy camu sigue
siendo un guía confiable para momentos
de incertidumbre sus ideas impregnan
Inspiración en lugar de derrota de
manera desafiante en un mundo sin
sentido
[Música]
la filosofía del absurdo de no es del
todo adecuada para usted con este video
ve así la vida de un estoico es una
mejor opción
[Música]